birmingham is bustling as it hosts the
commonwealth games demand for tickets is
at an all-time high
not so exciting though is the stir being
caused by tickets for an altogether
different event here at the
international convention center
it's the conservative party conference
due in october and all journalists have
to have tickets costing up to fifteen
hundred dollars each
people here don't think that's right
sounds like the conservatives to me
i think it's wrong democratically and
morally
but you know what it won't one of these
two politicians rishi sunak or liz trust
will have won a party leadership
election and become prime minister next
month that makes the conference even
more newsworthy but inaccessible say
some journalists it is unprecedented
charging media to access their party
conferences it is effectively stopping a
lot of people from going and therefore
it is a roadblock in in the uk democracy
so what's the fuss about the
conservative party is charging 150 for
journalist tickets booked early from
august the first they increase to a
thousand dollars and the week before the
conference they're up to one thousand
five hundred dollars the labour
opposition party tickets are six dollars
which it says is a voluntary carbon
offset charge
and it isn't just the scale of the cost
that's causing consternation a joint
statement put out by media and free
speech organizations along with the nuj
the journalists union in the uk
says that it causes a precedent to be
set and other countries in the world
could use financial barriers in order to
prevent media scrutiny of political
decision making
so should people be worried about the
media having to pay for access to their
elected politicians at a cost direct
different subjects
different subject altogether what do you
say i'm not going that is for the
conservative party to run but i am
absolutely clear the democratic
principle here is are the our
politicians available to and accountable
to the public and the answer is yes
boris johnson is on the way out while
controversy over how his party goes
about fundraising remains
his spokespeople say media ticketing
needs to cover things like security
checks and accreditation
critics say it's a tax on democracy
andrew simmons al jazeera birmingham